for almost 40 years you couldn't venture
into the waters of dingle harbor
without a well-known companion tagging
along
ireland's celebrity dolphin fungi wasn't
ever present here for 37 years
never gone more than a few hours if you
didn't see the solitary bottlenose
the dozen fungi boat companies would
give you your money back
now he's been missing for at least nine
days
the story has transfixed a country in
covet lockdown
marine biologist kevin flannery says
it's not looking good for the elderly
dolphin
basically what happens to all dolphins
at that stage is they're unable to catch
their own food
starvation or some infestation
internally or some problem goes wrong
and with his age profiling he possibly
has died of starvation this is the first
time since
1983 that these boats can find no trace
of
fungi in these waters over those decades
he's always shown the urge to engage
with and interact with humans
whether they're on boats like these or
in the water itself
local extreme swimmer noula moore has
swam with and photographed the dolphin
on many occasions
she says he's not camera shy i've always
noticed that and just as i'm about to
click he does this little pregnant pause
and he does this little um glint as he
and if you look at the pictures on the
surface of the water
he has this little moment where he looks
at you so it is my opinion
that uh that he poses it's not just the
local boatman who could suffer economic
consequences
in a town already missing its tourists
many other businesses here have
benefited from the dolphins presence
fungi's part of dingle has been
that he's unified so many businesses
people may come
to see fungi but from that they've done
fungi but they've discovered dingle
a full-scale search with sonar scanning
and divers has taken place
but now has been stood down the fishing
boats are still on lookout
but so far nothing fungi's disappearance
is as sudden and inexplicable as his
arrival
37 years ago stephen murphy sky news
in dingle